hello everybody hello hello we are back with more sleeping dogs where's my controller speaking of sleeping dogs i actually forgot all the controls for this game because we skipped a week of it uh because i was on my silk uh i was on my holo night era there uh trying to cram holo night as much as i can before silk slot releases tomorrow so i forgot how to play this again um this is that's it's the worst part about being a variety streamer um it's when uh you know because um i play a different game every day um like almost every day um so but when i come back to it you know a week later i come back to it it's just i'm like what are the controls because i have to remember five different controls as is tradition i know it's like but i know i think it's more so because it's really interesting because I've talked about this before but the audiences for YouTube and Twitch is very different in a way where YouTube people the audience on YouTube they like variety more in more of a way where
every day is a they want they they prefer to watch like you know something different every day so you don't want to play one thing all the time and but on on Twitch usually it's not really like what you're playing in a way so you can actually play a bunch of different things back to back to back for one day they also stream longer too I don't know how they do it I don't there's like there's no actual like order to like whatever they are playing because they like it's not really very easy to I feel like it's not very easy to watch Twitch VODs YouTube VODs,
because YouTubers, when we make a waiting room, it's usually that game.
But for Twitch streamers, they are more so of like, they don't really have a plan on what's going on.
They just stream whatever they want to stream.
And I feel like watching Twitch VODs is a lot harder than it is to watch YouTube VODs.
Just because it's like, I think it's more so like, you know, there's a lot of stuff, there's a lot of stuff going on.
as well so you don't really know what part we're at and it's not very like you know it's not very like organized very well so in terms of like what is what uh which is very interesting um and i don't understand how they i i don't know where they get their endurance from too because twitch streamers can stream for like um seven plus hours every day i i envy that because like after every
I like disassociate for like an hour or two because like I put all my energy in streaming And then after that, it's like, you know, my battery is sort of like dead at that point And I was like recharge mode I like I just disassociate for an hour or two,
depending on how long I stream for it And usually it's not even that long And then I just like like battery dead and I'm just like recharge Yeah, I'm like, recharging
me after every stream's over i'm like recharging
um solid snake thank you for the super chat thank you thank you don't worry dokey don't just grapple them and make them kiss the walls those are the controls easy thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you boy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hey your friends and you feel like streaming dokey anyway better get those one liners ready thank you thank you um but yeah it's it i i don't know how they do it i think it's also because like all my streams are like super high energy um like consistently throughout it because i don't like dead air that much so like i'm always like talking and i'm always laughing i'm always high energy so for me it's definitely is a lot harder and i'm also very aware of vocal cord stuff like even then like i still get i'm still very afraid of like you know um um damaging my vocal cords too much so i do try to like limit myself and i don't i try to limit myself and try not to like stream for like too much just because i know like how
much streaming can affect that because i still feel like we don't really have we've already seen like not even like long-term effects but already like some streamers are um experiencing effects on long period of time of just like two years of streaming especially when they're like you can tell that you know um and usually people don't recover from that too because i don't know if you guys didn't know for vocal cords um the biggest damage you can do is like those like notes like swelling in the notes and um and then it caused like bumpiness on your vocal cords and from that it's really hard for you to actually like uh recover from um from stuff like that and um and like usually it's like actually like you have to get surgery at that point if you have especially it's like it's basically career ruining in terms of like for singers and stuff because uh you don't sing the same same as like you used to um and it's harder like you don't hit the notes that you used to so like i try to be very
aware um of stuff like that yeah even my voice has changed if Even my voice has changed over time Because of like how long I've been streaming But for me, I talk in I don't like this is my natural voice So like I'm not pitching myself higher Or anything You might recognize like how But then you're just like oh no Like in the past you used to talk a lot higher Yes because when I first started out Maybe even higher.
I don't even know.
I can't really replicate that anymore because um, I was also very nervous when I'm streaming Um, when I get really nervous, I Pitched myself higher and it was like I don't stream that much as well Um, so I used to talk like this all the time and this was my normal speaking voice And it's actually crazy because I At that time that was Um That was my uh my normal speaking voice at that time um because like i when i streamed because like i was so like for that i don't know why i think that's just really nervous and then i just consistently talked like that all the time but then over time over time i like like slowly went back into my like natural voice because this is like how even then i think i still think there's sort of a streamer like I would sort of say this is like a little bit like my streamer streamer voice as well because off stream I talk a lot softer um it's actually crazy I actually talk a lot softer off stream I don't know but it's more so because like also because like I'm
trying to save my voice too off stream um and I'm not like you know I'm not performing you know I'm not streaming to So, off-stream, I actually talk in a lot softer voice because I need to save my, I need to save it for, I need to save it, and I don't want to,
like, strain myself too much or anything.
And, you know, I'm not entertaining anybody.
I'm just talking to friends or, like, talking to my manager.
And, yeah, when, if you guys ever see me, when I don't stream my POV on stuff, I do sound a little different.
Just because, like, you know, in my head, I'm like, I'm not entertaining anyone.
Like, it's just me.
I'm like if I am on your stream you entertain I'm just here like I'm just a plus one I if I'm not streaming and I'm just a plus one if it's a collab then I will like be I would be more like you know trying to do stuff for the stream But if it's like, you know,
it's my off day and I'm playing rank.
If it's my off day and I'm playing rank or like if someone needs a plus one, I'm like, I just like, like, I just go like a lot softer because I'm like, I'm not streaming.
I'm just hanging out, you know.
Doom guy, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
A man who never eats pork bun is never a whole man.
That is so true.
That should be like.
on those like um on those inspirational posters where the cat is just hanging on the tree uh yosh thank you the super chat thank you thank you on a question yoki what the fuck are park buns english is not my first language it's basically a bun with pork in it that's i don't know how to explain it it's a very hot bun with some pork inside like you but it's like bread and pork there you go whoa I know mind-blowing also um there's something really fucking stupid yesterday um and also like okay so um um yes I doki today you did something stupid like you did something stupid now yesterday so basically um uh I okay so this is something I've always wanted to do but like my parents never let me do it because like I don't know they always made a lot of excuse being like oh um you gotta measure everything and like it's just it's so much work to do so like I always had you know like when the sun starts shining when you're sleeping and the sun starts shining and then you wake up because the sun in
your like it's just too bright in your room and you wake up but you just want to you want to and you want to go back to sleep but you can't Because, you know, the room is too bright.
And the curtains don't really, like, block the sun.
So, there's something I've been wanting to do for, like, the longest time.
And it was to buy, like, those, like, blackout curtains just to keep my room, like, pitch black.
Because, like, I just... I don't care.
Like, I don't care about natural light.
Like, I just... I just want to sleep, you know?
I...
No, because I just wake up, like, a normal...
person so um i finally uh i bought blackout curtains like a few days ago and i got i got them like i finally decided to like put them up uh yesterday and i realized i bought the wrong size so it covers like half the window because it's a giant ass window like it's like it takes up the window is like two-thirds of my of the wall so so like it basically okay i'll draw what it looks like and and like the thing is i don't use like curtains for it they basically gave me like these velcro stickers and i just stick it on the glass and then like i just it's like fabric like i just it's not funny i don't because i was like i don't know how like because there's already like curtains like those blinders so i i couldn't really you know i live by myself so i can't like fucking take the blinders out and then and i rent the place too so it's like i can't really take that down because i'm worried i'll damage something so it's really me just like it's just me taping fabric onto my window so so okay
it's like so it's like the fabric is just it covers half of this and then there's the sun yay
okay here all right this is basically what it looks like um because i don't know what the size is of my way i just literally okay i should have measured it but at that time i couldn't find my tape measure and i didn't want to buy a new set of tape i just didn't want to buy another tape measure i have like five tape measures scattered around my apartment and i don't know where any them more i don't know so so it basically it basically um um it works though i still have blinders so i i use the blinders for the top half but they're still light because it doesn't really like do anything to be fair like like the blinders don't really help a lot but it does it the black the black curtains does help a little bit it's not as bright only half sunlight comes in um so so i basically like taped half the fabric uh you know i mean all the fabric so i just like you know i got the fabric and i just velcroed it onto the glass and i'm like okay that's good enough so yesterday i bought i bought this
another i bought the same credits and then today i realized wait i could have got longer Kurt I could have bought longer blackout curtains because there were two more options and they were both big I basically bought the smallest ones so I mean to be fair it was I it was just I just needed another half so it's fine I just so I was like oh wait they came there's another side So the one I bought was 148 width and 100 centimeters for height.
But the other options was literally like 255 centimeters.
And I was like, oh, I should have got that one.
That's double the size.
And that would have, that one would have really helped.
I was like, oh yeah.
You know what?
But I bought 255.
That would have covered my entire window.
So, I mean, to be fair, it was 50% done.
So, at least if I buy the same one, what do I need a toolbox for?
They gave me Velcro.
I just put it on the glass and then stick my fabric on there.
It worked 50% of the time.
It worked 50%.
So, yeah, so it's fine.
For your tape measures.
somewhere in my apartment.
I'll eventually find it.
So, you know, I'm slowly learning about life, you know.
It's like, it's like you chucked a newborn baby out into the real world and it's like, you gotta learn everything from zero.
Here's an apartment.
You gotta learn everything from zero.
And I'm like, do I get any help?
Here's Google and Amazon.
I'm like, okay, oh.
Also, also, I, yes, I did crash out after completing Hollow Knight True Ending because I found out that I could have completed the game, maybe 50, like, I could have completed the game maybe in, like, maybe in six hours or less.
If I had all my nail up Okay, I I need some one of you guys to rat this person out the reason why I like Mentally blocked the nail upgrade is because there was this one person's comment that lived rent free in my head Like every time ever since I started Hollow Knight and this person was like said if anyone can rat them out for me
I I need to know who this person is but this person said said in my chat or in the comments on or the youtube comments i don't remember they said you don't oh if you upgrade your nail the the nails upgrades will scale the bosses hp so that comment lived in my head because i kept thinking plus two should be fine because because then i don't want to scale too much of those bosses and then after i after like this morning i was like i need a no i need a fucking no like is this true and then i googled it and it was it literally was they were like oh yeah only some bosses like the dream warriors and i'm like this fucker
I could have I could have had plus a four nail oh my god I could have had plus four nail killing majority of these bosses the true one guide I that one guy made the stream 10 hours long
And, and so, I didn't realize that Radiance does not scale at all.
Radiance did not scale at all to the nail upgrades.
And also, like, all the other bosses, other than Dream Warrior, but, like, who fucking cares?
The Dream Warriors were so easy.
Like, I, like, the Dream Warriors, I literally, like, like one shot like not once I first tried all of them and like the four plus four nail would have helped the thing is I survived so long too that's the thing with my plus two nail I survived so long because but but like if I had plus three or plus four like I could have definitely killed them like I would kill them like the least amount like lesser tries because I was already doing really well with survivability because I was doing like fucking toothpick damage on them it was taking forever to kill them because eventually I will get hit like it's not like it's not like I will survive forever because eventually I will get hit because I'm not a fucking like speed run TSA inputter that would input these kind perfectly like I was doing it because I found out because I was googling I was like okay how bad was it how bad was the plus two nail and then I and then people were saying and I looked at the comments and people were saying that
my nail um my like my plus two uh was did was like uh was like uh 10 or like 13 damage uh it was 13 damage and i could have had 21 and i'm like oh my i could have cut this in half i was surviving long enough i was surviving long enough to like like i could have actually i think i could have killed radiance in less than 10 tries i i felt like i could have radius of less than 10 tries if i had plus 21 i i survived long enough for it boy i i'm all i'm saying is that i lived so fucking long i dodged so many things like
so i was i was literally playing with a handicap because of this one i got one guy so many times but that i don't know how i do it i will always read the wrong person in chat i don't know how i do it i just magically chose the wrong guy like
that was the old somehow it's always this one guy that gets to me out of everything and then the thing is i see no people are like oh but we were kept yelling at you to upgrade your nail and change your build and upgrade your build but i kept thinking about that one guy that one guy that was like if you upgrade your nail it scales the bosses and i was like if i'm where i can't know i was like in my head i was like i can't have radians have more hp i'm already fucking i'm gonna cry i i was like i'm gonna cry i don't want him to have more hp i'm gonna cry if he gets more hp
at that point and that's why i never upgraded my nail and then i found out and then after i killed after i killed it after the stream was done the 10 hour stream was done there people were saying wow she should have upgraded her now because it doesn't scale the boss's any game.
It's 10 hours.
It could have been a five-hour stream.
It really could have.
Anyway.
Anyway, let's play sleeping dogs and relearn the controls.
I like this game, though.
I really, I've been really enjoying it.
It won't be a very long stream today because tomorrow is still song release and we're going to be doing a long um we're going to be doing a long uh a long stream for silk song also the people who were like you could have asked chat at that point i was too far gone at that point at that point i was so invested in beating radiance that like i i didn't want to stop because if i stop give up and upgrade my gear they win who are no they will they win if i leave if i leave and change my loadout they win
I was not giving up I was too invested with what I have Because I knew if I bash my head against the wall Hard enough and enough times It will come down I don't need a change
Don't let them win Who is there?
They will win if I left.
If I left, because that meant I gave up.
And I didn't give up.
This is the Doki Way.
We need this on our men.
Thank you for your super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, they, no, they win if I turn around.
Never give up.
Anyway, let's play Sleeping Dog.
I feel like we've heard, we've been listening.
to like this fucking intro non-stop um nervous thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh doki never eats pork fun is never a whole doki you super chat thank you thank you um DJ thank you with super chat thank you thank you but you improved your gaming skills and we're seeing under level gamer achieve the true ending I am not worthy I acknowledge you my gamer lord right now zion thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right i don't remember what we're supposed to do because i think the last time we went on two dates and then i found out that um the i found who was her name what was her name what was that famous actress that had yellow fever i can't believe it i can't believe it i was just some hot American man for her to play around with.
Emma Stone!
Fuck you, Emma Stone.
I thought you were so cool and la-la-la and an easy, eh?
But I knew you were trouble.
How could you dump Ryan Gosling?
How could you?
He owned a jazz club.
He owned a fucking jazz club.
All right.
There's how she was at Easy A.
Biggest fumble in history.
Exactly.
She fumbled hard.
Max, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Two scoops.
You should go to the night market and get the funny straw hat.
They are super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, where's the night market?
I love night markets.
They're always so fun.
Asian night markets are so cool.
All right.
There's a fish market.
Dad left.
He's like, who's there?
He's like, please stop yelling about them.
Whoever they are.
All right.
He actually just left.
He left my room.
He was sleeping in my room in the bed next to me.
And then he left.
All right.
We might as well return to Jade Statue since we're here.
He's like, oh my, please be quiet.
Okay, I don't remember.
Okay, there's the cake.
I remember all my controls, so.
Okay.
I feel like it's not that many anyway.
All right, um...
Grab my cruiser.
I feel like the cruiser is pretty fast.
Okay.
Whoops.
I don't want to change my music again.
Okay, there you go.
Ninja...
Whoa!
I'm trying to remember how to drive this.
Oh!
Big horse!
We're just listening to ads right now.
Where the fuck is the sun?
Whoa!
Oh my god, learn my kung fu.
I gotta learn my kung fu.
How do I run?
Oh my god.
Wait, no.
Safety first.
Wait, guys, give me a second.
I gotta learn how to run.
Okay, it's A.
Hold A.
No, it's not copyright free.
I got copyright strike.
But, like, it's more so they just take my ad review, so that's fine.
It doesn't matter.
Wonderful.
I understand your sister passed.
She was an addict.
She couldn't kick it.
It's not a very interesting story.
I suppose.
But in light of that, my whole $5.
My whole $5.
to me anyway it's not like ad revenue is like everything is important because i have like you know i have so many vibes it like builds up over time but like the ones that do the like get the most ad revenue are the ones that have like 500k plus that's basically it all right what do i want this arm tackle is there anything cool you know i'll do the charged uh
arm break i want to learn how to break somebody's
Yeah, I like that.
How do I do this?
Tackle.
Is that it?
How did I decide?
I did not.
He's still holding it.
Okay, there we go.
I was gonna say, what do you mean?
He's still holding his fucking stick.
Okay.
Go pick it back up.
Okay, I did it.
That should be everything.
Back in there.
shit that's right oh i disarmed everybody you know what fuck this i'm that's right that's right using it against you that's right get out of here all right wait there's one more okay excuse me sir you're not allowed to do that's right get out of here get shanked i'll make this stick a shanker if i have to all right i did it do you remember how to block i did not pay the block do you really think you've known me for how long you expect me to block why block when i can just do damage if i damage them Hard enough.
I will never need a block again.
I legit... Okay, return the Jade...
Do I have another Jade statue?
Oh, shit.
Wait, I have another one.
Sorry, I'm back.
I'm back, Seafood.
I found one of your statues.
Oh, yeah, it's counter.
Okay, guys, you ever want to counter?
It was alright.
To have two homes is to have two souls.
Well, how do I counter again?
What if you never feel at home anywhere?
I think you must guard your soul carefully So as not to lose it What would you like to learn I'm slowly getting to breaking arms is it why okay.
It's the why button.
Okay, how do I do this?
Sun grapple Is that it?
Oh, and I do this Am I doing it?
Yes, I don't oh now I'm doing Oh.
What next?
What's next?
Thank you.
You know what sucks?
He's being paid.
He's being paid to get beat up by me while I'm just here returning.
I did get this for free.
I get this for free.
He has to be, he has to pay lessons to get beat up by me.
What an honor.
Oh, I have the whole, hold me.
What next?
See, fool.
What do I do next?
Oh, I break his legs.
Is that what I do?
Now what?
Oh, that's right.
I'll eventually learn.
I'll eventually learn what to do.
Oh, there we go.
Was that it?
See, fool.
I don't know.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Sudden grapple fall, there we go.
Thank fucking god, alright.
Back up!
Get back up!
That's right!
Get your ass back up!
And again!
Get up!
Okay.
Alright.
Get up!
That's right!
Aw.
That's unlucky.
Get up!
Excuse me, sir!
Sir, I'm trying...
Okay, this is like...
This move fucking sucks.
This move fucking...
Okay, this move fucking sucks.
I hate this move.
It's so hard to set up.
Oh my god, get up!
This move fucking is so hard to set up!
Get over here.
Oh, he's done.
You know, I can just beat them up.
Fuck this.
I'll just beat them up until they're over.
There you go.
Mission accomplished.
I just beat them up hard enough until they decide to leave.
I might not have done the actual move, but they all gave up.
And that's like, that's good enough.
That's actually good enough for me.
All right, new case.
Oh, here.
Okay, where I go here.
All right.
Next new channel, please.
New channel.
I want to hear some Chinese music.
I don't care about these English ones.
I can play GTA for that.
Give me some Kanto Pop.
All right.
Okay, that's just...
Is that British?
What the fuck is this the 80s?
Oh, hey, Golden Dragon.
Bum-bum.
What the fuck?
What is this?
Busy and Hawks?
Oh, this is my classical radio.
It's H-Club for life.
Some disco pop.
What the fuck?
Where am I...
Where's my cantopop?
Oh, that was what he's saying in Chinese.
I heard it.
Right here.
Inspector.
I'm glad you're here.
What do you know about the underground racing circuit?
Oh, no, not racing.
No, I'm not trying.
I'm not trying.
I'm trying to manslaughter at best.
But these last couple of files don't feel like manslaughter.
don't put me back in there deliberate feel to it you want me to check it out yeah get into the circuit and see what you can find i'm retired oh my god they want me back in oh my god text jackie about the race scenes i can't believe it they want me back in not again okay give me a sec dad wants like i i didn't fully feed him because like he was done he's been demanding food earlier and earlier and i'm trying not to like influence that but it is his feeding time i gave him a little bit at 4 30 so i'm gonna i'm gonna give him the rest of the food no he just wants the rest of his meal like i know he's like i know you're holding out bitch he knows he knows what he does he has
He's like, I know you're holding out.
Where's the rest of my meal?
Where's my food?
Who should I call it about racing?
Alright.
Ace, he is a friend of a friend.
Big race, he said, I'll let him know your car.
It's like when you're being recruited for a heist.
For one last heist.
I'm recorded for my one last big race.
uh nervous and meddy think of the super chat thing and they yeah and i'm like i'm in you son of a bitch i'm in i forgot where to go hand over the rest of the food one last race what do you say champ son of bitch i'm in all right Somebody in?
Alright, contact ace.
Yeah.
I'm Wei.
Wei Shen.
You up for a race?
Yeah, sure.
Long as you don't mind losing.
Alright, take the imp- Oh, impound it, car.
Which one?
You know what?
Let me get some fish balls.
Give me some gala udon.
I'll take some.
$25?
What a fucking scam!
What the fuck?
fuck all right okay there's this better be like ingredients imported from overseas that is so expensive what the fuck 25 even if it's in hong kong dollars that is so expensive for fish balls
rooster bakery i love bread talk support your local even local businesses it wouldn't be that expensive that is so expensive in hong kong
oh i miss bread talk red talk is so good yeah it's like a um i don't even know if it's a hong kong bakery brand but it's such a good break bakery brand
oh it's time to race
Oh no.
She was in the way!
I was taking a shortcut!
I was taking a shortcut, guys.
She was in the way!
It was an accident!
Oh my god, I don't remember how to drive.
Why would you just stand her in the middle?
Like, what's wrong with me?
her that's on her not on me i was trying to take a shortcut here she could have moved out of the way she could have easily moved like jumped away i don't know why she was still there
i don't know if i could win this race that guy so fast.
At least it's not like fucking mafia where you have to be first place.
Because that car I fucking sucked.
I remember.
Why would you stand in front of the cars?
She could have stood in the side.
That's all I'll say.
Why did she not stand on the side and then drop her fucking handkerchief or whatever?
She's the one that's stupid.
Okay.
Like, that's just evolution working.
That's just Darwinism at that point.
Look, I'm just doing survival the fittest right now, and I'm the fittest.
Natural selection at play.
Where I go here?
Oh, I am first.
Chad, if it was a man standing in the center, he would have met, I would have accidentally ran him over just the same, it didn't matter.
I chose my shortcut.
Good win, lucky for you, the one last man in the way, one in a million shot.
You want a rematch?
Yeah, sure.
Another rematch?
I won.
I'm ready for the big time.
let me know everybody knows i'm the best driver in the city everyone who the is everyone i'll take you down too hot shot just as soon as my car is fixed
yeah i won all right calling hkpd i broke into the street racing scene i broke more than one thing not only that broke into a scene i broke some bones too nice Impounded, nice.
I have a new car now.
I assume that guy is for racing.
I don't want to race them.
What the fuck is this song?
Oh my god.
Elegance.
Let's just listen to Mozart.
.
Oh my god, this is so, this song is used For Mozart, I mean it is Mozart, but the song is used for Maktao I remember the song in Maktao But
Oh shit!
Yay!
I made it.
There it is.
And I arrived safely.
Can I help you with something?
Yeah.
Are you ping?
No.
Poong and golem.
I'm just welcome.
I'm the owner.
I'm just not ping.
Are the owner?
Oh my god.
Successful businesswoman.
orange lotus sure this is some pretty sophisticated stuff i'm sure you can handle it i'll manage my number is on the package you need a hand getting slot x into someone give me a call she's the best girl oh my god my third girlfriend what the wait that's my hey hey what you doing get over here Bro,
do you see what I'm wearing?
Do you really think I have something good in that bag?
Look at what I'm wearing.
Why would you think I have anything expensive in that bag?
Like, get his ass.
Okay, she did not get, like, she did not get pushed, by the way.
It's true.
I would not rob this man.
Like, I would not rob me.
Like, what I'm fucking wearing.
right now in the i okay drugs in the out in the open in hong kong coming coming out of an electronic store at mid evening like okay that's it okay nice okay i had to counter him that's right oh no I need to put you get back up here.
I need to remember how I'll put you against the wall
There we go say hello to the wall I built Called a great wall of China for a reason That's right Give me back my bed my bag All right call Raymond Yeah, I built that built the city
don't let them see you planting that bug no a great wall of dokey that's working right get over here i need this car minus five thank god it's only five
don't make me don't make me don't make me Don't make me a turkey rat.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'll crush you in between that taxi.
I'll do it.
Wait, wait, I'm sick to take a chair.
I'm going to kill.
I'm going to kill people.
I'm not going to take a chair.
Oh Whoops, bump bump.
Oh, it's only minus 15
This is the best song to listen to.
Oh nice Hello I have to climb the construction area.
I'll use... Oh, that's good.
I use my car as, like, a little booster seat.
What do you say?
What did you say?
Say you're sorry right now.
Say you're sorry.
That's fucking right.
Come on.
Say you're sorry.
You know who the fuck I am?
I mean, I'm a nobody, but still.
Do you know who I am?
That's fucking right.
Say you're sorry!
That's right!
That's right.
Look at this weak ass.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, you want to fight?
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Move out of Hong Kong.
That's on him.
That was literally self-defense.
All I did was grab him a little.
bit how is that a crime I just grabbed him a little bit he was the one that that fought he like that fought me I was doing self-defense okay
oh is this what's this is this free money I got a jumpsuit okay
Yeah.
He threw that punch.
Hey, don't try that shit.
You got something to say, talk.
It's too easy.
This guy comes out of nowhere.
Just the dog guy is pressing us.
Oh, I'm scared.
I knew it when he was a kid.
Yeah, it's been since.
Oh, reminds me of what?
Oh, I have a timer.
Oh, shit.
I was too busy listening.
I didn't realize.
Hey, I'm getting some noodles from the kitchen.
You want some?
Why not?
I can't.
I'm going for two.
I'm going to go out.
Okay.
Calibrating.
Gotta twist it.
All right.
Nice.
Calibrated.
Hello?
Oh, it's also left.
Pick the lock on the back door.
all right where is it how do i do that
okay oh my god okay i got oh my
oh i did it nice easy never gets caught never punished look at that oh i think if i did I didn't beat up that one guy.
I would have been level two.
Yeah, what's she looking at?
Whoa!
Not ping!
What's she called me?
Look at that.
My third girlfriend.
Alright, let's see.
I need your help.
Wait, Tiffany?
Why do you need my help?
What's going on, babe?
Where's Tiffany?
Guys, I gotta help my second girlfriend.
Look, we're not...
Look, I never said we're going steady to all three of these women.
Is that her?
Is she the pink one?
Impressed, not pink.
Okay, not her.
Where's Tiffany?
Okay, but like...
Tiffany's asking for me, too.
That's police.
Yeah, but where's...
Tiffany she says she needed help where's the other pink one also what the fuck what's over there gambling den okay I gotta go there first all right ladies ladies I have something more important than either of you ladies I'm oh police officers in here yet all right there you go yeah get around this is my alleyway
all right all right what's this h club turn it up all right i'll be right back Ladies, ladies, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna be a billionaire soon.
And then I'm gonna invent Alibaba.
Alright, let's see.
How do I get over there?
I'm gonna find Alibaba after this.
Alright, I can swim through.
Oh, shit!
What's this license plate?
Wait, am I okay?
Am I...
here.
I got something else.
I got another important thing to do.
Where is he?
Where?
That's fucking right.
Oh, you're so lucky.
That's right.
You ain't leaving.
Get back here.
Not only that.
Get over here.
Get up.
Get up!
Oh, you see me?
I can't see no.
Where is it?
Give me that car.
That's fucking right.
That's...
Hey, what?
Wait, what you saying?
Get out of this car.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
All right, you're next.
You have something to say too?
Oh, you have something to say too?
Get out of this car!
That's so cute, right?
Yeah, I'm not stealing your car.
I'm teaching you a fucking lesson.
What about you?
Huh?
What?
Get out!
Alright.
You're gonna bow gang?
I am the police!
That's right.
Oh!
You wouldn't do something, too?
Get over here!
How about you?
Alright, he's fine.
He's cool.
Alright, let's go back.
Alright, there we go.
We fixed it.
We broke the cycle.
Guys, we broke the cycle.
Everything's okay now.
Clean up is complete.
It's okay.
We broke the cycle.
They all learned their lesson.
It only took a couple of bodies for them to realize what they did wrong.
They all realized what...
They did wrong.
Let's see.
How do I get over there?
Can I swim?
I should be able to swim, right?
Video games do not cause violence, I think.
Where the fuck are all the boats?
I'm gonna swim over there.
Go away, go!
That's right.
The ocean won't stop you from gambling.
It's okay.
It's not going to be like that powwow stream when I try to go to the oil rig.
This will be different.
It's alright.
I'm a...
I'll be Olympic medalist.
Wait for me, girl.
Girl is dedicated.
We won't let them win.
it's okay we can make it way the ocean is just water it won't stop us all gamblers must make this trek for the promised land exactly here we go i'm almost there i'm halfway you won't wait yearns for the i yearn for the the poker table.
It didn't stop the Titanic.
The iceberg stopped the Titanic.
That's just physical water.
I'm talking about liquid water.
Ain't no icebergs around me.
I will conquer the ocean.
How the fuck do I get up there?
Oh my.
Okay.
100.
We're so close.
I can see the promised land.
Right there!
It's almost there!
Oh my god, and then they spawned a boat in!
The game was like, please, we do not want you to swim all the way back.
Here is a boat.
I am the iceberg.
Yeah, they spawned a boat for me because they're like, We don't want you to do this on the road home.
Alright.
Hello.
I am here for the promised land.
I was promised gambling.
How do I get there?
I just climb over it.
It says do not enter.
Where the fuck?
Where do I gamble?
Where is my illegal gambling ring?
If I was a gambling ring.
Oh, is that the door?
through this door.
If I was an illegal gambling ring, where would I be?
Where the fuck is it?
Wait, I hear them.
They're inside.
He said, I'll talk to you later.
How do I get in?
Knock, knock.
I want to gamble.
Hello?
sir do you know what illegal gambling ring where the fuck is this illegal gambling ring i swam 400 meters i excuse me where is it oh where i unlock it later oh my god i can pay one oh my god no my I swam 400 meters for this illegal gambling ring.
Well, at least I got a boat.
I can't believe it.
I ain't even poor in this game.
I found a million dollars at the massage party.
All right, let me fucking turn down the goddamn radio.
It's so loud.
Holy shit.
Was the radio this loud the entire time?
That shit is loud.
I'll go down a little bit more.
All right.
Okay, I gotta figure out where to go.
And dock here.
Whoa!
I parked it.
Now no...
Look at that.
Good parking for me.
Oh, now there's...
Oh, what the fuck after I leave the deck postponed in?
Okay.
I can't believe it.
Now they spawned in.
Alright.
Wait, what if I call Tiffany?
That's Trent.
Hey, wait.
I need your help.
Where the fuck do I find Tiffany?
I thought she called me.
She texted me asking me for help.
Okay, let's see.
Where's my other lady?
Oh, I have to do not ping first?
Alright.
I'm complaining.
Let's go.
Okay, but before we do that, sorry.
This is much more important.
Sorry, ping.
I'll be there.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, ping.
I'll be there.
But this is...
Oh, hey, nice.
This is actually pretty important.
Nice.
We actually need this.
Oh Oh, they're too far Is that how you pronounce it?
I remember it.
I remember that quote from From all the uh From all the uh shun-hum-hum Deng si cat Is that how you pronounce it?
Oh, oh they're too far?
How do you pronounce it?
That's it's like a for the monks.
Unless I'm pronouncing it terribly wrong.
But I know that quote from all the Wukon TV shows.
Oh, ne, Tofa.
How the fuck do I?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm sorry.
The cock fighting will have to be another day.
I'm sorry, guys.
I know we want to see those cocks fight.
The roosters!
We want to see the roosters fight!
I'm sorry, guys.
We can't see them fight, guys.
Alright, can you take me to the area?
Alright, hire taxis.
Where the fuck?
Where's the closest?
Alright, take me to this clothing store.
Thank you.
now give me your car get out of here that's for overcharging me for this cab right
that's for over that's for how that's for giving me loops and loops we were so close to the area alright nice there
you are yeah I'm back yeah I thought I'd see if I could talk you into teaching me a few things okay let's go First thing is make sure the coast is clear.
Better get rid of that cop somehow.
Oh.
How do we get rid of her?
Distract the cop?
How?
By talking to him?
Having a nice conversation?
Excuse me.
Officer?
Yes.
What is it?
Yeah, I saw what looked like a drug deal a couple minutes ago.
Oh, by lying.
I'll check it out.
I mean, I could just do that.
I could just tell a cop, like...
Fake tip?
like that drug deal huh mchawa i have to say that the cops in this town are kind of dumb oh yeah yeah i'm gonna say it that seems very fucking stupid if i just go up to the cop be like sir there seems to be a drug deal in that alleyway could you go there alone please i don't think i can sweet talk them like you did though i don't know that seems really dumb if a cop like just be persuaded like that.
Info 4, it's an actual real drug deal.
Oh, that's easy.
What was the invalid placement?
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, this hacking is so easy.
How do you know how to do that?
I have my ways.
I learned it in the streets.
Girl.
I almost called her bitch, but I think we're not.
It's just the first day.
I shouldn't see that.
So, that I'll do that on the second date.
That's reserved for second dates, guys.
It's all sorts of crazy shit.
I bet.
You know, I still don't know your name.
I'm a gentleman.
Well, look at my address book.
You're still just not pinged to me.
That's cute.
I like that.
So you want to set me straight?
Most likely.
Oh!
I guess we'll see what it is.
Turned me straight.
That's what it means, right?
Yeah?
You're going to show me how to hide the camera?
That's what it means, right?
That quote?
Wait, where's not ping?
Are you ping?
What happened to not ping?
Where did she go?
I want not ping.
Alright.
Let's see.
Do you hear that 7-11 all the time?
The peep-peep.
Alright, now where's Tiffany?
Wait, where is Tiffany?
Okay, she should be at the club, right?
What was the club again?
Oh, club Bam Bam.
There it is.
Oh!
That's why.
Okay, let's go to...
Wait, I should be able to afford legendary outfits now.
I'm rich.
Ever since I went to that massage parlor.
Speaking of massage parlor, I'm feeling so stressed out right now.
Okay, we'll do this first.
Thank you.
She said nice driving.
That's so nice of her.
It beat us, drift.
Wait, what's this?
What's this next to me?
Is that comedian store?
Oh, that's just for Red Bull
All right, let's grab some some legendary outfits real quick There there's my Chinese music
All right It's okay.
I like those vouchers All right, give me a what do they have oh my god their hats the ghost pig mask classic black fedora Retro monster sheep white panda hats a sophisticated Wait, I think oh my god giddy up.
No, I have to have I have to have this What's this?
Oh wait, they have pre oh my god 50,000?
Okay, wait.
Lightning Warrior.
Rico Rodriguez.
Who the fuck is...
Wait, who the fuck is Rico Rodriguez?
Agent 47?
I can literally be Agent 47.
Oh, shit.
There's Wukon.
Oh, it's just guns.
Oh, my God.
I can literally be Wukon.
GSP.
GSP white training drunken fist.
Oh shit.
It's drunken fist unknown warrior vigilante You know in the game no point in chasing the market Yakuza style Okay, I need I want to save up for this though 350k This is what I want and then we're Okay What do we get okay, we can't do we get wukan?
who got in the triads let's do it let's yeah a lot of girls are into that you heard that look I have bills to pay okay ever since the gods held me hostage yeah okay with gangsta monkey you know wukon would have joined the triads if the gods didn't lock him up you know I I'm gonna get out of here.
Alright.
Now we gotta go to our favorite place.
We gotta relax.
Oh my god, there you go.
I don't get out of here.
Where's the eggs?
Oh there it is.
Is this the eggs?
Where the fuck is the oh there it is.
The Journey to the West adaptation is different than I remember.
Alright, I'm very stressed out I spent a lot of money today I don't want to think about money issues so I got relaxed in the one way I know how god damn it it's him oh my god I keep going there I all right this one
no I didn't say Wuka would join the triad if he had built I said Wuka would have joined the triads if the gods didn't lock him up
A massage is a massage.
If the triads existed and during the Wukon times.
Alright, I am so stressed out.
Ooh, ooh, ah, ah.
Don't worry, I got, you know those voucher coupons where they, every time you go there, you put a stamp on the coupon.
I get five more massages.
I get a special.
I just need to get five more massages, guys.
And then I get an extra one for free.
The 10th time is free.
Oh, and it's next to the club.
That's so convenient.
Okay.
Yeah, it's double stamps on Wednesday.
Oh my god.
And club Bam Bam is next to it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the costume stays on.
I'm in big trouble.
I really need your help, please.
What's wrong?
It's...
It's this...
A gun.
Why do you have a gun?
Charlie made me carry it in my purse for him.
That's very illegal in Hong Kong.
And now he's gone, and I don't know what to do with it.
Charlie.
He's one of Dog Eyes people, right?
Yes, and you took over, right?
So in a way, the gun is yours, too.
You'll take it, won't you?
Sure, I'll take it.
That's it?
That's a big problem.
Yes, thank you so much, Wei.
Oh, shit, free gun!
Oh, God, with my gun!
Look, this is modern era.
Yeah, sticks don't work as well as a gun, guys.
A long stick doesn't work as well as a gun.
Hello?
Raymond.
i got something what is it something for ballistics a weapon belonging to one of dog eyes men do you know charlie peng monkey with the glass can you use it all right meet me i'm on my way all right i gotta go meet raymond all right i need a whole movie about wukon wield we need modern era we need modern era wukon where he where he where he carries a gun is this way and then the gun can expand into a big like you know like how the wukon stick it turns into a long big ass stick the gun can turn into a fucking bazooka or a shotgun instead oh my god i'm fucking cooking any right any tv tv show company production company you want to pick me up I got lots of ideas.
I'll be the producer.
The Glock to an RPG or the shotgun.
And they could turn into a fucking sniper rifle.
And then like...
And then...
See Fule, the monk can be like a police officer.
And he's like...
Like Wukong would be like from the...
Like from the triads or some shit.
And then like...
Um, the, the monk can be like, don't worry, I can fix him.
He's a, he's a police officer, and he's here to, he's here to, and then, like, oh my god, it's literally sleeping dogs.
It's, you think about it.
And Wukong becomes like an undercover cop.
Wait, wrong direction.
Okay.
What the fuck do I do this?
Oh, it's two.
There you go.
Alright.
Alright, here you go.
Just film playing this game.
Pitch a TV show.
Andrew?
What are you doing here?
Where's Raymond?
This is something I wanted to handle personally.
Do you have Charlie Pang's gun?
Andrew seems seems like a corrupt cop They're always yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I was like how does he have a gun in Hong Kong?
Who's the dead guy?
I was hoping you'd help me with that actually Officer Shen he seems like a corrupt cop
Okay, you ready Yeah, too.
Why use gun when I have when I have the wall?
Oh shit Oh.
Flashbang.
We'll have to recreate the fight.
What?
In my head?
Just remember back then.
Shouldn't be able to know how I had a gun already?
Recreate the fight in your head.
First he was in cover behind the barricade.
How?
It didn't teach me!
Where are the guns?
Oh, LB.
Okay.
I want you to put some bullets in a few things.
Like the TV?
Um, guns are for shooting people.
Not for items.
That's a waste of bullets.
Fire shots using blind fire?
Oh.
Bomb, bomb!
What's up?
Boom!
Don't worry.
Something will happen.
Bop, bop!
Wait.
Shooting at the guys over there.
Oh, that was a headshot?
There we go.
Oh my god.
Bro, that's five bullets.
Okay, I need a headshot, apparently.
There we go.
There was a shooter.
Firing shots from the passenger You know
Don't worry.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
There's a game based off of that Pop pop pop.
Oh, I hit him
Oh shit.
Oh, you want me to bump wait.
That's the actual game mechanic for Whoops.
Max speed, yeah.
Okay, I'll...
Keep going.
Come on.
I'm trying my best, sir!
Okay, I did it.
Wait, he's still alive.
He would have tried to get away.
Oh, Conway.
But Charlie disabled the car.
Who's Charlie?
Oh, me.
Oh, shit.
My food's here.
Your weapon, officer.
Good firing way.
My pre-cooked meals.
Pendule!
What are you doing?
I told you he wasn't important.
Now he is.
He's going to help us nail Charlie Pang.
Wait, that was real?
It wasn't in my head?
I don't think I do, sir.
Way, I know who you are.
You're just like me.
You do what must be done.
I thought this was all make-believe in my head.
Where did this guy come from?
What?
Jacob, I told you.
It's classic Hong Kong movies.
The head police guy is always the corrupt cop.
It's such a classic.
Okay, we don't need... I don't need to shoot my gun.
Action, hijack, increased ramming damage.
It's always, oh, yeah, it's always the British guy, too.
Just like Rushad.
The British guy is the bad guy.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do I want to?
Do I, should I go all in on cars?
I don't, I feel like the guns are not that interesting.
I don't go in the cars.
Cars are cool.
Hong Kong opera is my favorite kind of opera.
Uh, anyways, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How?
What?
I was literally there for a cop job.
We got to lose the cops.
Don't worry.
I did it.
I lost them.
We just found out that Mrs. Chu's restaurant got hit.
Not Mrs. Chu!
Witnesses.
Where are the witnesses?
Where are they?
Oh, shit.
I had to go back to...
Oh, red-handed Tiffany?
Red-handed...
Wait, what?
What?
Wait, wait.
I gotta talk to Tiffany.
We were to say tip on hot shots, whereabouts.
I parked the truck nearby so he can bug his car and tell him.
Okay, I'll be there real quick.
I gotta talk to Tiffany.
I gotta talk to my second girlfriend.
Give me a sec.
Tiffany!
Wait, that's not Tiffany.
Who's that?
Where's Tiffany?
What's up?
some bad news for you you know tiffany from the club she's been stepping out seeing that long finger child on the side there's no way listen man i overheard her talking to him on the payphone outside her place no way maybe he's just a really good friend there's no way tiffany would never do that to me no oh my god why is your dead body here he was there when i got here guys Tiffany!
She's not like Emma Stone!
No!
She would never do this to me!
We had something special!
We karaokeed!
There's no way, there's no way, no way.
She might just be a really good friend of hers.
Maybe a family member.
How dare my second girlfriend not be loyal
Well, rules for the but not for me
There's this one right here Got a twist Don't worry, as a good boyfriend, I'm gonna bug her phone
Sugar lips?
You know I am.
I don't know.
I can't wait to see you again.
How about tonight?
I can't, baby.
I have to work late.
You sure?
I'd love to, baby.
You know I can't wait to taste you again.
But it'll happen next week.
If you say so, I'll call you.
But she calls me.
She said...
She said I was her only baby.
God damn, Tiffany, you were...
My second girlfriend.
I can't believe it.
We held heads.
Does that mean nothing?
We even held hands.
I can't believe it.
I'm going to tell my third girlfriend about that.
She's four on our streets.
I can't believe it.
And then keep one word.
His food.
What does she mean by that?
I got me an AMD's never sell burner that came with two And I got for crossfire purposes Thanks for paying the still keep brought back some happy memories Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you, I appreciate it And she means the food, right?
I can't believe it And then she misses kisses Because she's like I miss the taste She meant kisses, right?
Because that's what we Dude, we got the homerun and we kissed.
Can't believe she would kiss another man.
You find out?
Surely.
Can't believe it.
Wait for Tiffany.
I'll show her.
I'll show her what she's missing.
Is it because of the Wukon?
The ass outfit?
Tiffany.
I told you, I'm his number one fan!
If you can't love me in my Wukon era, you don't deserve me.
Ever since I went Wukon, I can't believe I will never change.
No, it can't be the gambling.
It must be the Wukon.
There's no way.
I got rid of a gun for her and everything.
Ladies love this outfit.
The Wukon elf.
Is it because it stayed on?
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, that's not...
I'm not possessive.
Guys.
She's the whore.
Wait, this is...
This is just...
justified she cheated I am allowed to do this she cheated so I am allowed to stalk her
whoa Toki said come but I'm not possessive Toki said calmly
Socking.
If she didn't cheat, I wouldn't be doing this.
My parents social.
Oh, she.
All right, here we go.
But Tiffany would have put our journey to the West together.
Who is he?
No!
How dare you!
Oh shit!
Sorry, wrong person.
Sorry.
Wayshend, motherfucker, who are you?
Oh, so the big triad gangster is mad now?
Only the big triad gangster can sleep with other people?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Who is this not a pink person?
You think you can fool around on me and I don't care?
She didn't mean anything.
third girlfriend you're number two you can go around jumping into other girls whenever you feel like it oh what's good for yang is good for yin okay okay i'm sorry all right i never meant for you to get hurt how did she know so you're gonna dump her now stay loyal to me wait how did she know we're snitched you know i thought you were different no
Please don't leave.
I'll make you girlfriend number one.
Please, please don't leave.
You are okay with Emma Stone Please not we didn't even go on a real date.
I just tracked her camp.
I was just showing her police stuff I was just hacking a camp.
Please don't leave me.
Don't leave me, please Please, let's make it.
Please don't leave me Don't leave me
Please!
We compete against Don't leave me!
Toki, what the fuck?
I don't know how to let go.
That's not Toki.
Please!
Please, I can change!
I swear!
Toki, please!
Calm down!
I swear I can change!
Please take me back!
push I don't understand I that pink wasn't even a sack the cell phone I'm so sad I lost it I lost my now I only have two girlfriends what the fuck am I supposed to do wait
Three was the perfect number Jill, she's not worth it quick fix.
All right, that sounds good to me
Okay Okay, maybe it's a quick fix.
Oh my god, there we go.
I knew it When life gives you lemons, make lemonade.
Hello, third girlfriend.
Check under the hood.
Wait, oh my god!
No!
After everything I did!
Oh, it's just that...
Oh my gosh, I should have just grabbed the car.
I should...
I should have grabbed the car.
and just fucking ran him over.
I dated.
I kept...
That's just sad.
That's so sad.
Holy fuck.
He just tripped on a box.
He tripped on a box and just died.
That's so fucking sad.
sad i should have took that car and ran him over away with a defied spear i'm so sad i lost i lost tiffany what am i supposed to do i lost her i can't believe it we had such fun times at karaoke
I thought we had something when we sang that song.
You dragged a guy across a bridge and broke his throat up for a thousand five.
Look, I had a broken heart.
I needed something to fix it.
And I know.
And I know what to do.
I got my coupon.
Yeah, they're coming.
Guys, is it actually possible to even keep Tiffany?
If I didn't cheat on her?
Was it possible?
If I didn't get...
Oh, what happened to my car?
My...
My game, like...
I wouldn't...
No?
It was scripted!
The game won't let me have three girlfriends?
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
What is wrong with my controller?
I can't believe it.
It was canon.
We were just never meant to be.
No.
It was just never meant to be.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
Now I have two girlfriends.
She loves me.
Is it because of the Wukon?
These girls liked it.
These girls love the Wukon outfit.
I need four more massages and then I get an extra free one on my coupon.
I heard, oh wait, it's double stamp Wednesday too.
It's Double Stamp Wednesday.
That was wonderful.
I got two stamps for that.
Don't worry.
I'm a VIP.
Massage parlor.
Massage the pain away.
Don't worry.
The massage parlor will massage it away.
She knows my name, guys.
I am a VIP.
What the fuck's going on?
Dog eyes shut up, Winston.
This mother's restaurant tonight.
Do you say who they are?
What's that just heard?
Your mother?
She's fine.
But two of our people were killed.
And a couple customers were wounded.
The police are there now.
Oh shit, I don't think the restaurant's gonna be okay after that.
I just heard five.
Listen up!
I didn't hear five.
All his drugs boosted that place.
It's how he makes his money.
want to burn to the ground see why runs the operation put that home got on that's the word you guys don't want me to say out loud are you sure about this of course i'm fucking sure look what's the chairman gonna say when he finds his warehouse floating in the ocean he's not gonna like it but there's no way dog guys walks away from this so burn the warehouse but take suah alive put him to work for you and give the chairman a bigger cut than he was getting from dog eyes okay okay okay do it bring him alive right boss don't worry i got you i'll make sure only he lives wait is she here guys is tiffany here hello do you know where tiffin whoa hey guys hey
You think Tiffany's here?
Tokey, please.
That's so crazy.
Guys, you know where Tiffany is?
Tiffany?
Tiffany, are you here?
Hello?
Is Tiffany here?
Lauren.
Oh, that's the first song I sang with Tiffany.
Stop singing!
That's right.
Stop singing.
That was our first song together.
Kind of cringe though.
Broke up with me.
Nobody can sing If I can't sing with Tiffany anymore No one can sing You're good with your hands, Shan Let's see what you can do without iron Look, hold up We shouldn't go in shooting anymore There'll be workers in there And we need to while alive Yeah Oh,
we're going in shooting This is dog eyes biggest moneymaker They're not gonna give it up without a fight But you want me unarmed You're the new guy Inside find your own gun when and use it.
Why am I an arm?
Believe me you better have some bodies on you.
I'm right.
I'm the one that's supposed to like fucking get him alive But you're not a cop As far as I'm concerned There's only one test that matters Killing people you want to kill one of dog eyes drug dealers to prove it?
All right It'll be my you mean the 20 other people I killed didn't count?
But yeah, I know if you're an Whoa, whoa, whoa, oh my god, I have to follow it.
We gotta know if you're an actual real cop because we want to kill a bad guy.
So I'm like, what, the 20 innocent people I killed didn't count?
You wait for my signal to attack.
If I kill a bad person, shouldn't that be the one that counts the most?
That counts the least?
To being cops?
You've
seen the new KVS?
The old ones?
Dealers.
Thinking the getting one?
Oh my god.
Are what, dog eyes, please?
You will, oh.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Sail onto the wall!
That's sucking right.
Journey.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
It's moving day!
Delivery for pain!
All right.
Nice.
There's no more.
Let's just put you against the wall.
A good one, Doki.
There you go.
Turning to the wall.
All right.
Hello.
That's looking right.
Oh, shit!
Avoid grapplers?
What do you mean?
Avoid grapplers.
They have Ramblers in here?
Alright.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
Alright, let's just punch him.
Because I can't put him against that wall.
JK!
Yes I can!
Alright.
I counted him.
What the fuck?
Where did this shit come from?
That's right.
Drawing to the west, baby.
Where did the stick come from?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Wait a minute.
Don't touch the metal.
It's high.
That's right.
It's time.
Genuine.
He'll walk it off.
get in line everybody get in line oh shit wait give me a sec I gotta oh shit all right get over here get over here okay give me a sec I gotta grab somebody I still have more who caught it barbecue is on the menu tonight okay wait I gotta just harm him.
I'm going to harm him.
He's got to be there.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, shit!
No, get back over here.
There we go.
No!
Get over here.
Who ordered the Tatsu?
Extra crispy.
Have a knife.
Let's go.
I did give me three boxes.
Serpentine!
That's fucking right.
Get this gun out of here.
I don't need no gun.
How do I just...
Okay, I don't need no gun.
All I need is the environment.
Oh shit, maybe I should have brought the gun.
Oh wait, there's the gun.
There you go.
Okay, I got it.
I got reloaded.
There you go.
But I got...
Oh, that did nothing.
Okay, I'm gonna vault over.
I need to get there closer.
There you go.
Slow-mo!
Oh, man!
That's what I could have used it for.
Okay, that is not cover.
That is absolutely not cover.
That guy stood in front of, like...
Like, stood behind?
I don't know.
This guy's fucking stupid.
That's for sure.
That's actually natural selection right there.
I don't know.
I'll get rid of this.
God, I hate shooting with a controller.
There we go.
Easy.
Wait, who's still alive?
Oh my god, wait, you're still alive?
This is not an overkill.
He deserves it.
Oh, shit.
Alright, up the stairs again.
Up the stairs, I'll go.
Oh, I thought he was alive.
I was like, holy shit.
Who's still alive?
there no no keyboard and mouse because this is more of a melee game okay it's up here give me a sec there's no way they know oh shit oh no wait SOMO!
SOMO!
Do you think he's dead?
Guys, do you think I got him?
What is it?
Shit.
Fuck.
Pop, pop, pop.
Fuck you!
You're not taking me alive!
Alright, let's go!
Beats, mouse, and keyboard yet again.
He has to come down, right?
What?
How the fuck did I not?
Oh, my God, it's scripted.
It's fucking scripted.
I was like, there's no way.
I literally...
I was literally...
right in front of him.
That's fucking right.
It's a hostage situation now.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
That's right.
Get over here.
Reloading.
Okay, there you go.
Get over here.
We're going out.
I'm taking a hostage.
Don't move.
Shit, I said don't move.
Fucking cops.
Oh.
Wait, where is he?
I could just do that.
Steal a cop.
Steal.
What about the cops behind me?
Oh my god.
Maybe these cops.
Oh, no, they're mine.
There they are.
I was gonna say, am I just allowed to steal?
Steal this?
Like, what happened?
Hold A when close to target press A when arrow turns arrow turns green.
Oh, shit, wait, he sold a car, too!
What the fuck are our cops doing?
There we go.
That's right.
Get out!
This is my car now!
Are you fucking done?
Okay, okay, I'm done.
JK, I was just...
I'm done now.
JK.
I got all the adrenaline now.
I'll just bust you around.
I'm sorry.
Bring him to...
Alright.
I gotta bring him to Bus Depot.
What did I do?
I'm not afraid of dog eyes.
Dog eyes?
Motherfucker, I get paid by dog eyes.
But all my product goes to Big Smile League.
You want to fuck with him?
Who's big smiley?
Wait, these are all cops.
Hey, hey, ask me if I care.
My brother is what makes the whole triad work.
Bro, what the fuck?
I just drove past all the cops.
I'm liable to forget I promised to bring you in alive.
What the hell is wrong with you?
You know what?
I'm sick of listening to you.
I want to hear the plot.
You'll get to meet a few.
Damn.
Used to be this organization knew what it was doing.
Oh.
The captain will drive too slow I was trying to listen to the blood
Look I got him Nice to mother fucking meet you From tonight on your partnership with dog guys is done
Take a bite of you We can talk about the terms of your new partnership.
What the fuck did the other people do?
They said they had guns, but who did they shoot?
A little token to my respect.
Oh my god.
Keep this up and there's a lot more.
That's a lot of money.
I'm going to be able to get my free massage, guys.
Hey, man.
It's still Wednesday.
Double stab Wednesday.
Cha-ching.
Sorry, I was wrong about you.
Massage money.
My massage allowance.
You know, I'm pretty sure I blew up the way.
house with all the bodies i burned i'm pretty sure i burned a lot of bodies okay well i get uh for my try it upgrades melee weapon resistance pacer back unlocks the form powerful attack melee weapon boost i barely use melee weapons.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we gotta grab this.
That's more money.
I gotta save up for my tactical uniform.
They'll never know I'm from the triad.
Surely they'll never know I'm a cop with that.
I gotta get that tactical uniform so they'll never know I'm a cop.
Okay, hot shot go to a street construction.
All right, let's go.
I'll save up for that.
Attack, yeah, the tactical triad uniform.
Unlock some clothes at the home, too.
Okay, but why would I ever...
Why would I ever change this outfit?
Okay.
And a health shrine.
Yay.
praying to my favorite guy guanyin is there a faster car there's all it's just like suvs tiffany tiffany said to me i can't believe it i can't believe she would do this i thought she was happy being girl i didn't realize being girlfriend when i added a third girlfriend that was her a lot i thought she was cool with that she was girlfriend too and she was cool with it but the third one was just one too many guys the third one was like her deal breaker
responders oh investigate the commotion it wasn't me i wasn't the commotion don't worry i got you Get out of this store.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'll call an Uber for you.
Inhale.
Oh, he died.
I wasn't supposed to kill him.
He just said take him away and I saw him being raided.
He's in hell now.
Stop scaring the customers.
Hey,
that's not even a grandma.
That's a teenage boy.
That's not even a grandma.
That's a teenage boy, sir.
You're so drunk.
Alright, now that the event is over.
He's like, save me!
Don't worry, I'll call someone to help you.
Inhale!
Oh, wait.
Give me a sec.
There we go.
Now I can do this.
Now he can go to hell.
Exactly.
Wait, where is it?
No, I just get experience for that one.
I was gonna say, like, does a...
Are you guys...
All right, that's a fast car.
Give me your car.
Yeah, yeah, I left him near the...
Exactly.
Wait, excuse me?
All right.
Don't mess with you.
Oh, you're a gangster?
Yeah?
Don't start with me.
Okay, I need to charge this up.
All right.
I'm practically a gangster.
I think this guy peed in his pants.
There we go.
Yeah, don't mess with you.
Say that again.
That's fucking right.
Don't mess with Soon Wukon.
You think you're bad?
That's fucking right.
Don't show your face in this neighborhood again.
I'm not teaching him a lesson.
He'll never respect me.
All right, I got it this way.
As long as we follow traffic laws, the cops will never get me.
All right, what's the next mission?
Weeeee!
Cinema.
All right, hello.
Wait, I got- don't you have a mission for me?
Come back!
Okay.
I thought you have a mission!
Give me a mission!
He's like, take the van!
Just leave!
Don, whoop.
You're about those traffic laws.
Look, every time you jump out of a car, you just gotta shoot your gun.
It's traffic 101.
What did I do?
Why did he run away?
I don't know about you, if you guys have a gun and you're jumping out of a moving vehicle, you gotta do it.
It's literally the first law in traffic.
As a viewer, I can confirm that is indeed in the park, in the driver's test.
Yeah, if you have a license, you know that.
Ooh, someone doesn't have a license there.
Not in a bug under Hotshot's car.
Oh, it's over here.
I don't think they'll know.
I'm just fixing his car.
Yeah, it's literally in like...
It's like the first question in the driver's test.
And then when you park your car, it's like what you have to do before you park your car.
Okay.
Oh.
Where is this?
There it is.
This one's the annoying part.
The two, well you have to twist two of them.
Back in the city van.
Yeah, we need a time to swap off the...
You're right.
I was like, wait, that's not my Wukon outfit.
I don't understand.
Is my Wukon outfit that suspicious?
Yeah, it's not that suspicious, is it?
No.
You won't know.
I'm also just parked up.
I'm just a little too close.
Don't worry, if I'm free.
I gotta be further back.
I blend right in.
You think he's a rat?
Or on the
go away?
So now he's in trouble if he is.
I mean, in game, what do I care?
But if I was you, I wouldn't let him see you do anything and walk away.
actually that is really bad like cop being a cop like just um just just like uh doing a raid on every bad thing that i'm at like that's a little stupid isn't it that's pretty suspicious you're supposed to like you're supposed to like what's the word like uh What's the word?
Like, paste it out?
Like, call him.
Oh, I already...
Yes, sir.
Inspector, it's way.
Hachat's gonna raise ace.
And he's talking like he's not...
Yeah, we gotta be low key.
Yeah, gotta be this streak.
I... Like, we should, like, paste the arrest and stuff.
Not, like, arrest stuff people back to back.
He's an informant for HKPD.
He's the one that put us on to Hachat in the first place.
You should, like, stagger the arrest.
You don't arrest every bad person that I'm with.
But not if it gets me killed.
Do everything you can to keep my cover intact.
I'll deal with Nas myself.
Alright.
Wait, alright.
And also let me kill more people.
Because they'll be like, there's no way a cop would kill 50 people.
That's fucked.
50 innocent people.
I should be allowed to kill 50 innocent people.
Just to prove to them that I'm not a cop.
Because I'd be like, that's fucking crazy.
One innocent person is already fucked up.
Wait, how do I drive backwards?
Wait, why?
Why stop after?
That's just a benchmark, you know?
I'd be like, yeah, that guy's definitely not a cop.
Yeah, I'm wearing a mask.
You won't know it's me.
Yay!
I did it.
Yeah, for day one.
For one day.
I should be allowed to kill X amount of people to prove it.
To, like, you know, not blow my cover, you know?
I'm trying to not blow my cover.
Oh, that's the racing one.
That's an enemy?
I'm going to beat that guy up.
Where is that guy?
There's apparently an enemy right here.
Oh, that's a lot.
Wait, there's money over here.
That's fine.
I got a wall here.
It's fine.
I got my wall.
This is my chosen wall.
Journey to the wall.
There you go.
I did it.
And I got money, too.
Yay, everyone.
What's your weapon of choice?
Wall.
all right yeah there's a certified wall banger all right guys wait i'm gonna call it here chat i did say today was gonna be a short stream and i tried to make sure that it would be like two hours around two hours because tomorrow would be an extremely long not extremely long not like 10 hours but it will be a long stream tomorrow with silk song so i playing that for uh for a bit um and it'll be at seven in the morning um no i haven't i didn't time it i just looked at obs to my left and it said i've been around almost two hours now hey guys uh i'm tired i'm already tired at least because i streamed 10 hours yesterday so i'm still trying to build up my uh energy back but i'm gonna grab some food i'm gonna grab dinner but i hope you I'll do two parts next I'm wondering if I should do two parts for silk song or sleeping dogs I'll see how I feel I'll see how I feel I might either do I'm gonna see how good silk song is um if I want to do two parts for silk song or two parts for sleeping dogs
next week any guys I'm gonna go hang out now I hope you guys had a great time watching as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys